[Musique]
en seulement quelques minutes et 10 minutes
On en reconnaît un en 15 minutes
Le feu commence avant un feu ouvert
ça veut dire qu'on peut le faire rapidement
combattre et ainsi réduire nettement les dégâts
réduire par rapport à l'optique
Des systèmes qui détectent en premier les incendies de forêt
visible au dessus des couronnes
nous sommes ici dans notre laboratoire où nous
le capteur à l'aide de l'artificiel
Enseigner à l'intelligence comment
différents feux de forêt sentent le noyau
ce capteur est électronique
Nez et reniflez maintenant comme de la fumée
d'une maison en pin, ça sent la tienne
Forêt de hêtres et forêt artificielle
L'intelligence sans ce modèle
le système d'huile aussi
[Musique]